[Musique]
regardez ce sourire pourquoi il souri
djoko figurez-vous parce qu'on est en
australie pour un match exhibition
devant 4000 spectateurs
tu comprends et ben oui on a beau être
numéro un mondial ça fait du bien voir
un petit peu de public on s'en lasse pas
donc le cerveau rabbit de retrouver
cette ambiance on va dire de la vie
d'avant 1 valérie que vous en pensez
[Musique]
l'australian open ça débute le 8 février
prochain la jauge de ce grand chelem est
fixée à 30 mille spectateurs par jour
sahir 50% mais c'est bien déjà on est
content de voir du public
parce que figurez-vous dans cet état-là
de melbourne l'état de victoria
il n'y a pas eu un 4 e vide depuis trois
semaines et ça ça va nous faire du bien
voir un peu de monde dans les tribunes
une image de festival vous dis à
personne
enfin si il ya une personne s'appelle le
festival c'est le plus grand festival de
suède de cinéma qui vient de démarrer
ils l'ont appelé isoler et cinéma
cinémas isolés ils ont proposé à une
personne d'assister à la projection de
tous les films voilà donc les 4 mai 2004
mais demande et finalement je ne sais où
c'est en suède met en scène deux femmes
grandes amies mort en selle un acteur
c'est pas un mec qui joue un rôle c'est
ainsi celui là est un con c'est pas
luchini qui fait son souvenir ça c'est
chiant la semaine le public s'emmerde
20000 personnes dans les rues de
jérusalem hier pour l'enterrement d'un
rabbin une figure de la communauté
ultra-orthodoxe
les images sont hallucinantes un
rassemblement au mépris de toutes les
règles en vigueur en ce moment depuis le
27 décembre vous l'avez d'israël est
sous le coup d'un confinement très
strict sur ces images caler quelques
masques pour la forme et pas besoin de
regarder très longtemps pour voir ce que
c'est loin d'être la majorité le 7 août
c'est une vraie bourde gaffe une garce à
bien jouer le comble c'est que ce rabbin
est mort du coronavirus pas de quoi
susciter une prise de conscience de la
part de cette communauté ou d'une partie
de cette communauté qui depuis le début
de la pandémie et parfois violemment
s'oppose aux restrictions le pire c'est
que dans ce contexte la police ne peut
rien faire elle est obligée de laisser
faire
jusqu'ici cette fois c'en est trop pour
julien et marque
il embarque que l'individu
les allemands sont ils en train d'ouvrir
des camps pour enfermer les personnes
qui ne respectent pas leur quarantaine
sur les réseaux sociaux de nombreux
internautes opposés aux mesures de lutte
contre le coronavirus relaie cette
information
en établissant des parallèles
germanophone avec les camps de
concentration du régime nazi
une nouvelle preuve selon eux que nous
vivons en dictature sanitaires pourtant
cette description outrancière ne
correspond pas à la réalité
d'abord je n'ai pas rencontré de
dictateur je vais fui je les aime pas
non plus puis en plus c'est très délicat
de voir effectivement j'ai pas rencontré
d'hitler
j'ai par contre et 2 sort encore
président de quoi juste le président
russe a pas ce que nous voulons c'est a
dit le chef etc soit de sa cause je ne
dirai jamais que c'était clair quatre
länder sur 16 ont décidé de mettre en
place des structures centralisant les
personnes ne respectant pas une
quarantaine à domicile obligatoire pour
l'instant il s'agit de neuf chambres
d'hôpital sous surveillance dans le bade
wurtenberg d'un centre de détention
juvénile reconverti dans le
schleswig-holstein d'un centre de
détention pour migrants accommoder dans
le brandebourg et d'un ancien centre
d'accueil pour réfugiés en saxe et selon
les informations de la presse locale
une seule personne fait actuellement
l'objet d'un isolement forcé dans l'un
de ses centres
fait chier c'est pourquoi je bois plus
ou alors je bois très vite
salhab le bois pour essayer dé prouver
d'ivresse et pour pouvoir tomber en
toute liberté
mais au tournant je bois plus parce que
ça me fait chier à peu sa bosse à céder
on est triste à la fin c'est la
naissance de culturebox une chaîne
entièrement dédiée à la musique au
théâtre et à l'art en général un projet
imaginé pendant le 2ème confinement faut
répondre à une crise sanitaire qui
s'éternise il fallait aller plus loin
puisque la situation ne s'améliore pas
pour ce pour ce secteur et on s'est dit
que lancer une chaîne éphémère c'était
la possibilité de permettre aux artistes
de montrer ce qu'ils faisaient
nous sommes actuellement direct à la
télé allez-y il ne vous sera plus aucun
mal si vous regardez j'en ferais tout ce
qu'on voulait je pense qu'ici font
beaucoup d'effets de manche c'est de ne
rien d'ailleurs parce que c'est quand
j'entends l'autre là le mec habillé en
noir et qui on n'a pas envie de
l'écouter
quant au vaccin on comprend rien majesté
roger jeu devrait la voir depuis
longtemps parce qu'entre le coeur cinq
plages l'asthme le diabète est toute la
merde le surpoids
y'a rien n'y a pas de vaccin quand
est-ce qu'elle prendra fin cette
campagne de vaccination puisque il reste
beaucoup de catégories de population à
vacciner et par exemple des gens comme
moi a priori bien je suis dans la
dernière étape du plan
j'ai voulu faire le test sur un site
internet vaccin planeur donc moi je suis
jeune je suis en parfaite santé je n'ai
pas de contre indication aux vaccins et
aux rythmes de vaccination actuelle je
ne pourrai donc être vaccinés que dans
deux ans i'm so excited même des
réformes
ok à quoi tu vas être attentif à ce que
j'ai payé un détail physique qui te fait
craquer
je dirais qu'il faut qu'on le soit plus
pauvre de toi ah oui tu insistes tu as
bien une religion
oui trouvé ton style n'est pas commode
appelle la déesse de la mode
et si tu la connais pas d'état cristina
cordula assurément l t'aidera personne
ne l'a détrônera krysna je tire ma
révérence pour nous tuer une référence
[Musique]
ça se passe aux et de washington là bas
il neige beaucoup regardé c'est la
première fois que cependant voie de la
poudreuse il s'appelle tiana est
visiblement laurent il vous fait fondre
complètement craqué intelligence de
l'animal qui se dit d'abord qui a la
réputation d'être un animal qui sait se
détendre et prendre la vie du bon côté
un peu à la balle ou à regarder comme il
est inspirant il se roule dedans
pas besoin de remontées mécaniques n'est
ce pas manger comme un cochon être une
poule mouillée ou tout simplement
paresseux
voilà le genre d'expression que la péta
aimerait voir disparaître au motif
qu'elle participerait à l'oppression des
animaux ce tweet de l'association de
défense des animaux est jugée exagérée
voire ridicule même par certains vegan
après ça ouvre la porte à de nombreuses
questions est ce que dira j'ai la pêche
où j'ai la banane est oppressif envers
les fruits oui peut-on dire de quelqu'un
qu'il est marteau sans insulter les
outils voilà de vastes débats
c'était avec